(soft music)
- [Myra] Voila.
- Thank you.
Wow.
Okay.
I'm going in.
- Just go for it.
(soft music)
(phone buzzing)
- Hello?
What?
Oh, my god.
- What's going on?
(sobbing)
- My mom.
- Oh.
(sobbing)
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Come here.
Fuck diabetes, by the way.
It's such an asshole.
Just,
promise me that
neither of us will ever die.
(slow, dramatic music)
- Hello, Myra.
Just so you know, I will not
be looking at your penis today.
- No, it's not that.
I've just been
incredibly hungry.
I'm starving.
I'm so thirsty.
Drinking so much, but
it just never goes away.
The thirst never goes away.
I'm peeing more than I'm not.
It's just one constant
stream of urine.
I had to duct tape my cock.
No matter where I am,
it just keeps coming.
I can't stop it.
- [Doctor] You're
peeing right now?
- Yeah.
My vision has been so blurry.
I can't even see.
I don't know where I am.
I'm so tired.
I'm wildly fatigued.
- You don't have diabetes.
- Yes, I do.
I definitely have it.
(sobbing)
(upbeat music)
(door opening)
Where were you?
- Having my mom cremated.
- But I missed you.
- What do you want me to say?
- Will you just come over here?
I made some cupcakes.
I love you,
and this probably is
gonna be so hard to say.
But just promise me when I die,
you'll turn my skin
into a leather satchel
and carry me around 24/7.
- Why would you die?
- Well, 'cause, I have diabetes.
- That's paper.
- At least you just went
through this with your mom,
so now you know how
to take care of me.
(coughing)
I just can't believe my
time has come so soon.
I'm gonna go sit down by
the blood pressure machine.
Promise to walk me
out when you're done.
(coughing)
- [Doctor] Jade.
- Dr. Jay.
Hi.
- I heard about your mother.
- Yes.
- She's dead.
- Yes, I know.
- I am so sorry to hear that.
- Thank you.
I know.
And now Myra too.
- What?
Myra?
I just,
last month, I took
a look at his penis.
Was there an accident?
How did he die?
- Oh, no, no.
He has diabetes.
- Oh.
No, please, he
doesn't have diabetes.
- Oh you should
see him, he's sick.
- No, he's fine.
Physically, he's fine.
- He...
- No.
- You...
(coughing)
You don't have diabetes?
- Not technically, no, but,
baby, when you're
dying, you just know.
I don't expect
you to understand.
Just to wait on
me, hand and foot,
until my final days.
(sobbing)
(dramatic music)
♪ How could I have known
♪ That you would be my baby
♪ That you would
drive me crazy ♪
♪ My heart was very lonely
for a long, long time ♪
♪ But then you came my way
♪ Don't stop runnin',
playing around ♪